[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio y las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa sectores
conservadores en eeuu apuntan contra
netflix acusándolo de sexual izar a las
niñas el escándalo estalló cuando la
plataforma promociona la película que
uriz con un póster muy polémico y
distinto al aprobado por su directora la
cinta que busca denunciar la
sexualización de las menores terminó
siendo acusada en eeuu de convertirse en
lo que critica mientras que en europa
tuvo gran acogida empezamos
las redes sociales se habla mucho de la
película franco senegalesa mignon o
curis en inglés a principios de este año
la cinta recibió el premio a mejor
dirección en el festival de cine de
sundance pero esa no es la razón por la
que se convirtió en tendencia en el
mundo de internet
el largometraje trata sobre una niña
musulmana de 11 años que se siente
presionada por su familia en busca de
libertad se une a un grupo de baile y se
deja llevar por la influencia de la
cultura digital
netflix anunció que la película estaría
en su plataforma pero el póster de
promoción desató la ira de sectores
conservadores estadounidenses en la
imagen se veían cuatro niñas posando de
forma sensual y con diminutos atuendos
muy distinta a la fotografía promovida
por su directora esto desató una campaña
en internet acusando a netflix de
promover el tráfico sexual de menores y
la sexualización de las niñas bajo el
numeral cáncer netflix usuarios en
internet hicieron un llamado a cancelar
su suscripción también pidieron a
netflix retirar la película la
plataforma finalmente ofreció disculpas
pero no frenó su estreno la situación
fue muy distinta en europa especialmente
en francia donde la cinta se exhibe en
salas de cine
de cultura respaldó a la directora del
largometraje mientras que en regiones
como américa latina'
no hubo debate al respecto
lamentamos profundamente las
ilustraciones inapropiadas que usamos
para mignon cutis no estaba bien ni era
representativo de esta película francesa
que ganó un premio en sundance hemos
actualizado las imágenes y la
descripción políticos estadounidenses
también han tomado partido cuando faltan
menos de dos meses para las elecciones
los republicanos han aprovechado el
debate para acusar a los demócratas de
no hacer nada para defender la niñez
aunque varios demócratas han condenado
la película como la ex aspirante a la
presidencia tools y gabart y christina
pelosi hija de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes nancy pelosi el
rechazo a netflix se ha multiplicado
entre los republicanos congresistas como
el senador ted cruz han acudido al
fiscal general para que investigue y
determine si hubo violación de las leyes
federales contra la producción y
distribución de pornografía infantil en
la página change.org donde las
peticiones no tienen repercusiones
legales pero generan presión social más
de 700 mil internautas firmaron para que
la cinta se elimine de netflix según la
usuaria que creó esta iniciativa las
firmas serían redirigidos al fbi para
qué
a los padres de las actrices al personal
de producción a su directora y a netflix
según may mineduc ugt directora de la
película su objetivo era arrojar luz
sobre el problema de la
hipersexualización de las menores agregó
que su largometraje ciertamente inició
un debate pero no era el que ella
pretendía en un artículo escrito para el
washington post narró la investigación
que llevó a cabo para crear la historia
la idea nació cuando vio a un grupo de
chicas bailando de manera atrevida en
parís y quería saber si eran conscientes
de lo que hacían
youtube entrevistó a decenas de
preadolescentes que le dijeron que
trataban de imitar a mujeres sexys que
veían en instagram un texto creyendo que
eso las haría más populares su
conclusión fue que estas niñas
construyen su autoestima en función de
los me gustan redes sociales y la
cantidad de seguidores que tienen la
directora agregó que el proyecto incluso
fue aprobado por las autoridades de
protección infantil del gobierno francés
y que un consejero capacitado estuvo
presente en el set
nosotros como adultos no les hemos dado
a los niños las herramientas para crecer
saludables en nuestra sociedad quería
abrir los ojos a las personas a lo que
realmente está sucediendo en las
escuelas y en las redes sociales
obligándolas a confrontar imágenes de
chicas jóvenes maquilladas disfrazadas y
bailando sugestivamente para imitar su
icono pop favorito quería que los
adultos pasaran 96 minutos viendo el
mundo a través de los ojos de una niña
de 11 años mientras ella lo vive 24
horas al día estas escenas pueden ser
difíciles de ver pero no por ello son
menos ciertas aunque otros usuarios en
redes defienden la película y adjudican
el origen de las críticas a una mala
campaña de marketing por parte de
netflix esta no es la primera vez que la
plataforma se ve envuelta en este tipo
de escándalos el más reciente estuvo
relacionado con la que hoy sigue siendo
una de las cintas más populares de su
catálogo se trata de la producción
polaca tn y 365 a la que acusaron de
romantizar el secuestro y los abusos
pese a las críticas y peticiones la
película sigue estando disponible lo
mismo ocurrió con la comedia brasileña
la primera tentación de cristo' en la
que el hijo de dios es presentado como
homosexual
grupos evangélicos el congreso y el
mismo presidente ya ir bolsonaro
ejercieron presión un juez de río de
janeiro ordenó su retiro pero la corte
suprema de oración revocó la medida
el semanario bar ayer y citó datos de
una firma de análisis que reportó que
tras el estreno de crisis la tasa de
cancelaciones de netflix en eeuu fue
ocho veces más alta que el mes anterior
pero se negó a proporcionar estimaciones
sobre la cantidad de clientes que
cancelaron en los medios de comunicación
de eeuu el debate tuvo un tinte
partidista contrario a los medios
franceses por ejemplo en el programa de
ingram angol de la cadena favorita del
presidente de trump foxnews se habló de
que la izquierda impulsa el
empoderamiento de las mujeres mientras
sexualiza las niñas la comentarista
laura ingram acusó a los demócratas y a
la industria del entretenimiento de no
proteger a los menores una columna en la
revista the new yorker titula iuris el
extraordinario debut de netflix que se
convirtió en el objetivo de una campaña
de derecha dice que la historia de la
indignación y el desafío de una niña al
orden
al cual resultaría irritante a la
derecha en francia la revista marie
claire defendió la simple rescató que
abordará la preadolescencia dijo que
este es un periodo muchas veces ignorado
por el cine el diario le figaro cita en
su título a un grupo de directores
franceses que dicen que el boicot a la
película es un atentado a la libertad de
creación hasta aquí revista digital
recuerda que si quieres repetir esta u
otra misión de nuestro programa lo puede
hacer a través de nuestra página web www
puntos france24 puntos
[Música]